For higher order roots though, we need to do something a little bit different.
If you remember we had a product rule that let us split up a root of a and b.
If these were factors of a radicand we could split the root up into the nth
root of a times the nth root of b. Well it turns out there's a similar rule for
division. The quotient rule let's us take the in root of a fraction we can just
split it up into m through it of a divided by the m through it of b. This means
that the cube root of this fraction becomes the cube root of 27. Divided by the
cubed root of 16. We're just using our quotient rule. We know the cubed root of
27 will end up being 3, since we can rewrite 27 as 3 cubed. But we can't
exactly take the cubed root of 16, 16 is 2 to the 4th. We don't want this cubed
root to appear in the denominator, so we need to rationalize this part. If we
can get this power to be a multiple of 3, then we would be able to take the
cube root of it. For example, I really want this denominator to become the
cubed root of 2 to the 6. I can take the cubed root of this, it's just 2
squared. So when we reationalize the denominator of a higher order root. We
want to raise the power of each factor of the radicand to be a multiple of the
index of the root. In other words, we want to have powers inside the radical
that are evenly divisible by the index of the root. So, what would be multiply
this numerator and this denominator by to change our denominator into this
form? Keep in mind that whatever we multiply the denominator by we need to
multiply the numerator by since we're really just multiplying by a form of 1.